america is facing multiple crises at
home
this is our historic moment of crisis
and challenge
and unity is the path forward
the biden administration will have to
fire fight on many fronts
you submitted your questions on biden's
first 100 days in office
john fasman the economist u.s digital
editor
and charlotte howard new york bureau
chief have answered them
how can buy them tackle the pandemic and
secure economic stimulus
are more than 10 million fewer americans
employed now than before the pandemic of
course
more than 400 000 people have died so
he's got a lot of work to do
and he's trying to think very
ambitiously about how to help
both contain the spread of coved ramp up
vaccinations and get american
workers back to their jobs back to more
normal employment levels get the economy
back going again
so he has a really ambitious coveted
relief bill
that would give 160 billion for vaccines
he wants more
testing more contact tracing in terms of
economic relief he wants to give 1400
to americans boost the child tax credit
temporarily in a way
that would have child poverty there's a
lot that's part of
what president biden wants to do and
it's kind of an opening salvo we'll see
how much support he can get from some
colleagues on the other side of the
aisle
for this scale of help i expect he'll
get it i expect it won't be
the full amount that he wants he's
proposed a 1.9 trillion dollar
package that sounds big enough to be an
opening salvo
the number comes down and he picks off
some republicans they were willing to
send out direct stimulus checks with
with
with donald trump's name on them i would
think they're willing to get some money
into the
into the pockets of americans who who
need it now too
water biden's plans to tackle the
climate crisis
biden has this very ambitious plan as he
laid out
during his campaign that includes
getting the economy to net zero
emissions by 2050 having a clean energy
standard so you have clean electricity
uh by 2035 a huge infusion of investment
into research the types of things that
we might need including
carbon capture and sequestration uh
batteries
hydrogen all kinds of different things
that we
would need in order to achieve that net
zero goal and then he also wants to
to try to do this in a way that creates
millions of jobs for
ordinary americans and i'm just
scratching the surface in terms of
what's included in this climate plan
and the question is how he would be able
to get some of this stuff through
congress what he can do through
executive action clearly he's going to
try to roll back
some of the regulatory steps that donald
trump
made or rather reintroduce regulations
that donald trump tried to roll back and
try to do that through executive action
but there's a lot of stuff that
really requires the cooperation of
congress and i don't think that you are
going to see
necessarily one big comprehensive
climate bill
and rather you'll see climate infused
into federal policy
in all kinds of ways that includes
through all of president biden's
agencies not just
the environmental protection agency and
not just the department of energy but
commerce the department of
transportation
the securities and exchange commission
will biden reform immigration
well on his first day in office as
promised he sent a legislative proposal
to congress that would create a pathway
to citizenship
for for millions of undocumented
immigrants currently in america
he also wants to reinstate uh daca
deferred action for childhood arrivals
that's a policy that protects people who
are brought to america
as young children who grew up here who
they lack proper documentations but who
have known no other country this is
their home
so he did both of those in the first day
now
laying out a pathway to citizenship
which is something that that people have
been chasing for a long time
requires legislative approval the
problem with that is that for as long as
i've been covering washington for as
long as i've been paying attention to
politics
comprehensive immigration reform has
really been the white whale of congress
people have wanted to do it there has
probably been majority support
for any number of proposals generally
that offer some combination of a pathway
to
citizenship for the undocumented with
increased enforcement at the border
that's always been the sort of broad
contour
but the problem is an impassioned
minority has always been able to block
it
i think that there may be some
motivation there after the past four
years
to get something done but we have been
here before
and so he needs legislative buy-in
whether he gets it is unclear
how can biden make progress on race
relations in america
biden spoke about systemic racism on the
campaign trail
often and i think when people hear that
phrase what they pay attention to is the
second word of it is racism
but i would encourage you to think about
the first word as being perhaps the more
important of the two
systemic racism refers to racially
biased policies
that function absent the active malice
of anybody implementing those policies
that is because
american policymaking has been so
steeped in racial bias for so long
that there are inequities that get baked
into the system and you really have to
root them out
and so i think what the biden harris
administration will do
is in every policy that they enact is
just pay attention
to those unintended inequities that are
perpetuated by any policy they propose
so for example nobody would come out and
say as a matter of policy
we have to give covet vaccines to white
people first
but if you decide to give out vaccines
through pharmacies which is i think what
what
what america plans to do what should be
done and there are
too few pharmacies in majority minority
neighborhoods as there are
then what will happen is that white
people end up getting vaccinated at a
greater rate than non-white people
to avoid that happening you need to
actually pay attention and set up
policies to stop that from happening one
of the executive orders
that that that biden put through was to
set up a coveted equity task force to
say
look we know that there are systemic
biases
across multiple systems what do we do to
counteract that what do we do
to actively deliver vaccines ppe
n95 mass other things in a racially
equitable way so i would think you're
going to see a lot of that
involved in the policy making process
across the entire administration
across all the executive departments the
other thing that i think
is is really valuable and it seems
strange
to even have to say it but having a
president who's very
open and clear about condemning racism
and condemning extremism
is is hugely important we had people a
mob
breach the capital it wasn't just any
mob it was a mob
bearing confederate flags and it was a
mob
wearing shirts with anti-semitic slogans
and you did see um these what i would
call extreme factions of american
life burst into public view and burst
into the mainstream in a way that we
hadn't
in a long time in addition to the
systemic racism
that has been part of american culture
for a long time
um so i think that having a president
who fully tries to push those factions
back out to the fringes
rather than embrace them and give them a
platform you know the importance of that
can be overstated
can biden fix income inequality in
america
i think that there's a theme here which
is there's not going to be one
income inequality bill but biden is
going to
take a number of actions whether
it's trying to raise the minimum wage
expanding uh the childhood tax credit
investing in education thinking about
how to use
spending to mitigate climate change to
also promote
jobs whether it's construction jobs or
manufacturing
all of those things i think are part of
this broader effort to think about
how to help those who feel like they've
been left behind
in recent decades and try to narrow the
income gap
you know i'm not sure which of those
will be
successful there are some that clearly
would do a lot i would highlight
the childhood tax credit which would
have childhood poverty it's really
remarkable how effective that is as a
policy tool
income inequality the climate crisis
race relations these are the work of
generations
but the work of governing is moving the
ball
incrementally closer to the goal while
knowing that you probably won't get
there
and so what you're going to see on on on
the inequality front
is someone who who thinks it's a problem
who takes it seriously
and who'll implement policies across the
range of government to try to make
things better and that's what government
really is supposed to do
how can fake news on social media be
addressed while maintaining freedom
of speech i think that that
looking for a way to quell the divisions
and stop
untruths is misgiving because there are
divisions within any society that get
expressed through
whatever form exists to express them in
a healthy democracy
finds a way to to to channel them
productively to not make them make them
destructive
i do think what you'll probably see is a
lot more attention
paid to regulating the big tech
platforms
i think there's a general agreement even
if it's still tacit you will probably
see a general agreement come to the fore
that twitter and facebook are in many
ways media companies
and should abide by the same rule as as
the same rules as as other media
companies um but i think it's a mistake
to think there's some switch we're going
to flip
to make social media you know
completely placid and honest when that's
not what our society is or has ever been
is there any legislation that could help
to unify
americans i mean the short answer to
that question is
no that's not really the job of
legislation right the job of legislation
is
to is to legislators to pass laws and i
think the question of unity is a bit
of a red herring i think what what
people should hope for
is not unity because there are genuine
disagreements about policy about culture
about the right way to live and a
democracy has to
entertain those disagreements and those
disagreements are are perpetual
um and i think that what so i think what
we should look for instead
is way to perhaps turn down the
temperature of partisanship
so it's not quite so rancorous and i
think the way to do that
the way for joe biden to do that is is
just to be
you know competent and boring i think
we've had 12 years of presidents
who had real die-hard fans who people
were really deeply passionate about
i don't get the sense that joe biden
inspires that same level of
love and devotion and i think that's a
good thing i think it would be good
if americans instead of thinking of the
president
as the embodiment of some sort of
national ideal or as a savior
thought of him as you know someone they
hired to do a job for a few years and it
doesn't work out they'll hire someone
else
as john pointed out he is the right
president for this particular
time you know kind of dull but also
sincere
and i think that we'll see how much he
can get done
you know we'll see whether he's able to
forge the type of bipartisan compromise
which
his team claims he can uh but i think
that
in many ways you know given a very very
difficult challenge
he's probably as best positioned as we
could hope a president would be to try
to move things forward
when he gave his speech on the uh
on inauguration day where he spoke about
how the task of trying to bring
americans together
um it's his big task as president and
that his whole soul is in it
you felt that he really meant that i'm
jon fassman
the economist u.s digital editor you can
read our latest coverage of the biden
administration by clicking the link
thank you for watching and please don't
forget to subscribe